we must be takeover yep
I think we might make it stop
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that so several submitters have
mentioned the terms such as quite
Catherine such feel have any moral
Center those things that we are in
discussing about providing for you and
the district planet before so we see
from the star positive things in here to
build on Republic there are no elements
in the institution's received that would
cause us to us
change with special plan is prison
remind you that it is an aspirational
document
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
landscape architect which basically
means anything outside of a building I'm
based in turnery I've been practicing
landscape architect since 2004 and have
a background prior to that in lots of
things but especially plastics and
concrete and civil construction I'm
pretty well-traveled and I've lived all
over New Zealand and it finally settled
in Turpan area I want him to live there
for about 15 years
it kind of was the shortest driving
distance the most places for work and
I'll just are pretty much really my read
my submissions verb
as I as I wrote it it's referring to
who's in the spatial plan document so
I'll just I'll just read them off some
of them are things that I think should
be done some of them are where I think
there was a lack of information or maybe
the doctor can sedentary explored far
enough so there's quite a few questions
that worthwhile considering I've got and
then sort of urban planning in town
planning as well as regional planning so
little bit further than carbon design
remained the main center yes also to
stop its sprawling sprawl zagore means
building on flood prone land building on
high-class soils over time sprawl
results in a town losing its center and
becoming decentered I believe the 21st
century will be marked by profound
reading stealing of towns it's pretty
much the only way that you can come in
under that reduce the carbon threshold
we're not going to be electrified fast
enough only takes 50 to 60 years new
fuels that get out of society so the
town will shrink so the risk is that
you'll end up with stranded assets you
know if the council does say a small
subdivision out on the outskirts or
beyond the outskirts that that asset
could become stranded there's no one
want to walk to it infrastructure Gore
must seriously consider
[Music]
three water strategies
so that's sewage water collection storm
water treatment I know that Gore has a
three waters three waters staff and
three water strategies that's not going
far enough and if you really go even if
you reduce your cattle expenditure quite
a lot like 12% cities that have done
this overseas towns and cities
addictions yeah it's generally about 10
to 15 percent they actually cut their
expenditure over a period of years it's
not instant but if pretty much starts at
the level of private properties and
winds out from there in this in essence
it's like devolution in Delta individual
Lots there are enough residents who
understand this sort of these approaches
now that I believe you can do this
without threatening local politics which
does seem to be a thing that comes up
throughout New Zealand especially in
Cheaper mixed juices so strongly favor
run well it strengthens everything local
and leads to an ever-widening local
circular economy and there was something
about infill and I support that also
like infill because it tends to employ
small local builders rather than large
operations like purchased which come in
and possibly to rake the place and move
out also town should consider rail and
we have a rail line running through it
used to be railway stations all the way
through for passengers fifties and
sixties that's kind of gone but the rail
line is still there so they don't want
the town to do anything a lot or remove
access to those because again rail is a
very low carbon technology one of the
few ways into the future many industrial
processes you know if you go for single
use zoning which the doesn't which the
RNA was brought in to do away with or at
least treating them or flexible way and
you're sort of doing away with a whole
lot of modern ways of doing things
richer a lot listen
is dust vibration etc there are all
kinds of machining technologies and 3d
printing type technologies which they're
quite an oculist compared to their
forebears no-go areas and development
unless we start managing landscapes from
a catchment basis we'll see ever larger
and more frequent floods as we're seeing
all the time now I know a lot of people
don't like climate change from warming
but there's something beyond that's the
actual co2 level itself it's actually
changing plant growth making plants more
efficient in the way they use water and
people all around the world especially
in Switzerland Germany just showing up
water runoff is increasing without
increased rainfall many people in this
room are farmers understand plant growth
and they understand what carbon dioxide
actually does and how much plants
actually you need beyond a certain point
it's not fertilized this actually sensor
threatened everything we need to address
these things terror yeah I strongly
support focused on making the town
friendly for larger businesses that can
make use of state highway 1 and railway
but we need some small business focus as
well otherwise and so one does one
business town and it's boom and bust
happen always seen that and many other
places have seen their and Mandeville I
can't speak to the people at mandible
never lived there
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
no better way to lower our carbon burden
if you're being promoted international
and there are hundreds of these fly-in
towns especially in the States but also
in Europe it's a great thing and flying
isn't getting around fashion even the
fuel I know at the moment who is
negotiating to buy an electric passed
aircraft from Czechoslovakia he lives
and done eating he's gonna buy it and
bring it out here and fly this isn't the
future features now and what better way
to town that's B steam and wings Y feels
to me like the town's lost its center
this is real life style I many of my
clients are farmers and a lot of them I
see that actually commuter fires they
have a lifestyle block which has been
central part of their farm sometimes
they might have multiple either farms or
a distributed farm and they commute out
to the bits about 30 percent of small
blocks are actually commercial entities
in some form or other this is the
lifestyle made to sound like something
people wanted or it's just playable
there to more serious I just ask could
that especially poor somewhere like why
can't it be reflected in all our writing
to encourage locals to stay local
you know why caius seems quite robust
and as it's been in contemporary as it's
been in other places
mandible why character doesn't seem to
be doing that pop her out don't I don't
support encouragement lifestyle there
make it easier established businesses
there make the most of that commercial
frontage I wonder and again these are
questions I don't have answers for
myself but is this something about
specialized seasonal work that leads to
more transient workers this is going
back to a question than the
documentation and also are people
checking wore out and they're moving on
to greener pastures
with the cupboard is probably going to
be seventy-five to a hundred thousand
people returning from offshore and
they'll probably stay here for the long
term just as happened after 9/11 in to
some extent after Bali I really need to
make now communities attractive to these
people because a lot of people are going
to be traveling around in the country
once they can get back in find somewhere
to live biodiversity and important
landscapes core needs to ensure that the
forestry including carbon forestry does
not take over high-class soils farmers
tell me that long term beater performs
better than trees and certainly employs
more people and it employs more people
more local growing trees is really
highly and high in depend upon a low
cost oil to show things offshore and
finally another thing about carbons and
I'll bang on the bell and people just
planting trees all over the place
forestry is just being carte blanche
going ahead
there's some trace carbon in the ground
is ancient and must be across the year
but there is deeper carbon in deeper
soils below the plow layer below the
working back that's there for a very
long time but if you grow the wrong
trees or trees into those soils and
these soils are not everywhere but there
are some recently good soil surveys of
some of this data you can release that
which will just pack on our carbon
signature for the country by something I
believe in giving agency the farmers to
actually build this carbon in because
you can actually make this stuff in
situa as well not just through forests
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
those couple of things that you
mentioned
what reference was it you talked about
single-use use science so I believe it's
a good thing done right implying as
close to the same well for instance you
might have evening time offices you
might you might have offices and are
more into the evening and you've got
light or medium index drill that's
through the day
and later into the night people can live
closer to that area it's also some
people who may be wanting to live on
their premises so they make their own
noise they look with their own noise
when they stop making it not basically
play or work they plan to sleep by
design is that we [ __ ] on a single
title
[Music]
[Music]
you
and so forth does allow for more of a
sustainable dry day
these ideas not really poor documents is
reluctant but a lot of money of you if
you imperfect some of its then Sam they
are a to hold it
[Music]
the storm water for their firefighting
system Phoenix and likewise when you
look into three waters
if you run everything on flushing
toilets whereas as opposed to composting
and other semi composting systems there
are precedents now in New Zealand with
us
there are complicit commercial building
in East Tamaki large the bar complex
which has a cause it has a composting
system step built-in foot so that
building losses is not connected to suit
has no impact on the solar system at all
and likewise if if stormwater is treated
carefully you can actually not load the
stormwater system of the town at all
swales and basins but normally these
things are treated as purely engineering
creatures and the plants are just pretty
good but you can actually transpire you
can plant putting 70% of the water into
the air it's a matter of cracking right
plants and steering the soil and pros to
do that no one's well I've done one in
New Zealand a couple of others
throughout for others there was a lot of
short lowering many countries and states
we should really be pushing it because
it's true from its resilient people can
understand it's not a black box you can
trick so far as thank you
they worship thanks for the submission
it's good just a question can you
explain
just one men new fracture and processes
that a quarter
I believe understand live in the
strength and there's a mole when the
models have brought together the salient
water is washed through this electric
current and after about a week turbine
blade pops out but it didn't involve any
casting any welding any hot systems and
almost no noise there are dozens of
processes like this now that are very
quiet so if you go and say that you're
going to have it single used heavy
industry because of say you're heavy
industry is predicated on what someone
makes rather than how they make it um
you know you could put one of these
things in your house but you know it
will be quiet there's no vibration nor
would know it was there so if you
predicated what goes where based on what
people do you're kind of losing out mmm
this way you can have mixed yeast you
can't have mmm you could have one of
these kinds of technology running in a
building where people are sleeping
[Music]
[Music]
Waddy Europe CRM a the RMA was based on
basically avoiding effects I think it
needs to be taken further than what they
do so that no observable law needs to be
there for very low level but
technologies in thinking and planning
can enable much greater compactness
[Music]
discussions changed omega-3 for
recommendations attached to because
anybody was to make this three worship
it's just the last recommendation is
that having considered the submissions
make no amendments we make a special
play I don't think it's a long time to
consider the submissions maybe we should
have a discussion around
[Music]
that USO council will be using the
special plan to direct staff and out
that star cluster coming out of these
are the step to show you step down to
uncommon when there is a tools that
bring up these types of concepts
so we've listened to the gentleman talk
about winning areas of flood promise and
having centers to towns and so forth
which is where we already has some
specials with honors committee about
applying I forget the name Padma case
what is typically a low-density ten
trips down to areas such as white hacker
to provide that at the variables which
need to be picked up at a staff level BC
notices I believe being able to the
integrated into the mystic pile exercise
I don't actually see anything not to be
able to be happy I think that there is a
facilities to be brighter than what we
see needs in terms of exposure plan this
is very much so and bear in mind that if
we think of this as a series of layers
in fabric that makes sense and this is
the beginning this is beginning where we
start to fall shape to the minister to
step down is going to press the shape
interest from the initial chain people's
just see more detail we don't we he
needs to use concept on the discussion
with the community about how that could
be used to facilitate there's two traps
which is the moment assemblers
industrial just got really remember and
so there are whole series of things
there that we've got decisions of how we
would tools to gain a specific outcome
and that outcome is quite well I think
in the submissions we've received and
the indication of that is the indication
that is in the diagram format Eric you
know we have an arrow pointing towards a
revitalized commercial area
with the garden
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
but
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
we straight forward to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah story eka contains all the
locations
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the counselors too
[Music]
[Music]
here's got CJ we didn't get into the in
point to the end point and um I thought
I was quite prepared to say anything
well we didn't really miss out on the
scene those examples of the work I think
it's all paid in past years and it was
really good to have those I mean we
didn't actually see them to a minute's
Lucchino came out and I miss
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm looking to revisit the decision to
not offer free some business to all
children in the district it was made
using lines of venison at time not to
continue the program opportunities the
opportunities arose and teams reviewing
new national thinking this area
we should
[Music]
[Music]
people will speak more detail rather
than us all those different versions
[Music]
freely around the country statistics
thanks to come forward and just give us
some yes sir is pointed at the
statistics and rope and water safety and
New Zealand and then 18 years ago a
program is first of all it was designed
around
[Music]
so completely that we came from parents
come through year we had one specific
had the instructor whose trial put the
program down to the Amina and Sarah
didn't realize to get me out of trouble
and they had a right away
the initial derated from second-youngest
honest he's won three they need to be
the swimmers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's give the district program its
concentrate on our district area so they
must all be catered for but it will be
under the Sun they usually school
swimming pools around
yes okay so thank you open for
discussions or questions I'm sorry I'm
essentially automation I would like to
say that we should acknowledge the [ __ ]
he's contribution over the last three
days as bright and that's when you go to
see in TT being on board even though
this considerably
you're just amount of money about so I
gave them time to come a little
contribution again because I think this
is a really good program
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Thank You kisses throughout this brings
us to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cheating their committee so three
councils one has the cheer - there's
been this
[Music]
[Music]
Thank You counselors